In the Washington suburbs, salespeople at this grocery store selling halal foods...
...are trying to keep up with demand right before the beginning of Ramadan.
For Muslims, it's a special time of the year.
It's a peaceful month and a month of mercy and it gives me a lot of energy.
Several million Muslims make the US their home.
Many observe the fast in America as Muslims do overseas.
In my opinion there is not any difference.
That the rule is one.
There is no different kind of rule, Ramadan is Ramadan.
So maybe the difference is the time.
In our country, the time is 12 hours of night, 12 hours of day.
But here, it's maybe a little bit longer that we fast.
That is the only one I see is the difference.
Muslims fast during the day and break the fast at nightfall.
Many like foods that are special for Ramadan.
While these shoppers are trying to wrap up their shopping...
...before the start of Ramadan,...
...the shop owner is trying to stock everything they want.
During the beginning of the holy month of Ramadan,....
...mostly Muslims focus on fresh dates, meats,...
...all kinds of meats, halal meat, plus spices, fruits.
I already got enough dates and all kinds of supplies for Ramadan.
Many stores adjust their hours to suit the needs of their customers.
During the Ramadan, of course,...